[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
ihr seht ist schon was werden wir heute
machen nur das werden wir noch mochte
und weil sich viele herz auf der flucht
gelungen gewünscht haben gibt's heute
herzhafte buchte als salzig ella fakten
immer warum heißt das herzhaft ernsthaft
ist ich würde später füllen mit einer
hackfleisch pilz füllung ihr könnt die
aber füllen womit ihr möchtet ihr könnt
mozzarella und tomate reingeben ihr
könnt das ganze vegan aufzubereiten ihr
könnt wirklich machen was ihr wollt wir
probieren sitzt heute erstmal mit
hackfleisch teams und dafür werde ich
jetzt den hefeteig herstellen und den
könnt ihr wirklich als basis für alles
nehmen was einfach locker fluffig und
luftig sein soll
ich bin heute übrigens nicht karohemd
zelle sondern streifen 13
nur zur info jetzt hat und hefe teig für
den hefeteig verwende ich einen würfel
hefe das sind 62 gramm 20 km
zuckerrübensirup 150 gramm warmes wasser
180 gramm butter milch oder kefir zum
beispiel zweier 750 gramm mehl 2
teelöffel salz und 120 gramm weiche
butter
das war es schon ich habe die zutaten
immer das heißt ich kann immer
herzhafter buchteln aufzubereiten und
statt butter milch wie gesagt auch käfer
oder ein oder normale milch das geht
auch alles
ihr könnt jetzt entweder einen vortrag
herstellen oder direkt loslegen ich
nenne es direkt los die hefe ist da drin
zuckerrübensirup nehme ich jetzt ganz
gerne weil einfach die farbe des
hefeteig dann wunderschön wird und das
hat auch so ein leicht nussigen
geschmack aber stattdessen könnt ihr
auch honig oder zucker zum beispiel
nehmen dann das wasser dazu und
geschwind verrühren
kurz vor
schwimmt sagt schwind lebenstag uns bei
euch
nein okay dann sag nur bei uns in baden
im see deutschlands
ich erinnere mich noch an eine situation
in der fünften klasse erdkunde fragte
mich mein erdkundelehrer daher schäfer
saliha wohnen wir auf der nord- oder auf
das südhalbkugel
und ich antworte südhalbkugel und dann
haben sie mich alle ausgelacht
ich hab's dann verwechselt mit
süddeutschland kann ja mal passieren
laut dem in der fünften klasse wie kann
man in der fünften klasse und mädchen
aus lachen was und geografie schwäche
hat ich habe sie heute noch aber heute
lache ich selber drüber
aber das war schon schon gemein na ja
wie gesagt wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr den
hefeteig oder den vorteig jetzt noch
kurz aufgehen lassen ich habe aber
direkt weiter geht jetzt hier die
flüssigkeiten dazu bei hefeteig einfach
nur darauf achten salz und fett immer am
ende dazu geben damit einfach nicht
direkt an die hefe daran geht die eben
schön aufgehen kann dann das ist alles
hier drauf und ich geb dann das meer
langsam dazu und je nach milchsorte kann
sein dass ein bisschen mehr oder weniger
braucht und dann den teig einfach etwa
zehn minuten kneten bis er schön
geschmeidig ist er darf nicht zu weich
sein denn wir wollen ja hoch sind raus
kneten aber eben auch nicht zu fest
das gebe ich auch die butter dazu und
ihr könnt ihr natürlich auch mit der
hand erklärt es dauert halt ein bisschen
länger und ein bisschen auch wenn wir ja
dass ich den einfach kneten und räumen
da wird schon mal auf jetzt denkt
perfekt durchgeknetet ihr könnt gerne
auch immer die hände so leicht finden
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich schon chris kraus
four minutes 100 kugeln und dann darf
abgedeckt für eine stunde auf gehen oder
in der küchenmaschine für eine
dreiviertelstunde stunde oder im
backofen bei der stufe für eine halbe
stunde so dass er sich einfach schön
verdoppelt und ihr könnt bei der menge
an mehl gerne auch die hälfte der hilfe
menge benutzen aber ihr müsst dann
einfach nur wissen je weniger hefe umso
länger müsst ihr aufgehen lassen
also das ist einfach völlig normal und
ihr könnt auch bei diesen rezepten die
selbst vermerke hefe benutzen aber wie
gesagt einfach die längere aufgezeigt
beachten
das ist dann schaue ich dich
[Musik]
und dann gerne die oberfläche auch
fetten und aufgehen lassen und ich kann
ihn da zwischenzeit schon mal die
füllung zu bereiten
für die füllung nämlich zwei esslöffel
olivenöl eine zwiebel und einer
knoblauchzehe 500 gramm hackfleisch ich
hab so zeh vom rind 250 g champignons 40
gramm tomatenmark hier noch die gewürze
salz pfeffer paprika edelsüß und
backbone coach und 50 gramm schnittlauch
also das sind jetzt hier meine zutaten
das tomatenmark und den schnittlauch das
habe ich jetzt aus dem gefrierfach die
habe ich nämlich immer auf vorrat
denn ich habe mal acht kilo schnittlauch
geerntet und das reicht jetzt
wahrscheinlich für immer
naja was sich jetzt zuerst machen werde
ist das olivenöl erwärmen einfach in
einer großen pfanne in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die zwiebel und knoblauchzehen
fein hacken
das hackfleisch hier direkt in der
pfanne anbraten
es ist schön krümelig anbraten
immer gleich so verteilen damit sich so
ein großer klub bindet
sag ich immer kurz war es weil ich ganz
auf die frage bekomme was passiert denn
wenn was in gusseisen top four in der
großen pfanne anbrennt hier seht ihr
dass am anfang das hackfleisch hier so
ein bisschen anbrennt und zwar weil ich
da an der stelle jetzt einfach kein fett
hatte hier sieht man ganz gut hier
bremst nicht an
aber das löst sich dann auch gleich
durch den fleischsaft einfach wieder von
ganz alleine und oftmals ist einfach so
dass man dann entweder zu viel hitze hat
zu wenig flüssigkeit oder fett oder eben
einfach das falsche gar groth im top und
jetzt gleich zum beispiel wie gesagt
hier kommt er jetzt der fleischsaft so
ein bisschen raus und es löst sich jetzt
beim kochen von alleine wenn ihr das
problem öfter habt dann einfach mit
einer flüssigkeit kochen oder eben ein
bisschen mehr fett weil es ist ja keine
antihaft beschichtete pfanne und
normalerweise war es aber immer so dass
man gusseisen auch hat bisserl ein
brennen lassen und vielleicht kennt ihr
noch von ihrer oma oder ur-oma sogar die
hatte dann einen großen gusseisen bräter
und der wurde dann auch immer nur mit
wasser ausgewaschen stadt mit spiegel
und statt mit spüli und mit seife
einfach weil sich dann eben irgendwann
diese beschichtung bildet aber man kann
auch sauber arbeiten und sagen okay ich
war schon eine top mir lieber komplett
aus und wir leben nichts drin und keine
antihaftbeschichtung keine party dann
muss man einfach beachten nicht zu
verletzen
feuchtigkeit oder eben genug weg bei mir
ist das hackfleisch jetzt schön krümelig
ich habe es jetzt übrigens auf stufe
acht von neun also ich mach da auch
nicht auf volle pulle weil es einfach zu
heiß wird das material ist so ein
schönes dickes schweres material und da
muss man echt nicht immer auch voller
pulle arbeiten nicht auf power boost
gebe ich die zwiebel und knoblauch
würfel dazu zu dürfen schönen mitgaren
bis sie weich sind also bis sie glasig
sind da gebe ich einfach kurzem deckel
drauf
früher dann gleich nochmal durch und es
dauert so zwei bis drei minuten hier
ruhig ab und zu durch
habt ihr jetzt auch noch weitere
untergestellt damit nichts anbrennt also
höchststufe 5 6 und jetzt kann ich in
der zwischenzeit schon mal die
champignons einhaken
die werden übrigens nicht gewaschen
sondern nur geputzt
also champignons einfach nicht waschen
weil sie sich wirklich voll saugen mit
wasser jetzt die champignons mit braten
die haben jetzt auch noch
restfeuchtigkeit das darf jetzt hier
auch alles ein bisschen verkochen das
tomatenmark dazu und das habe ich dann
gesagt vorher eingefroren denn ich kauf
ganz gerne tomatenmark in so einer
großen verpackung packt dann in meiner
eiswürfel formel 1
und jetzt für euch hab ich's ausgepackt
aber normalerweise gehe ich ins
gefrierfach und haben wir dann zu zwei
eiswürfel rein also tomatenwürfel und
dann habe ich das auch schon jetzt kann
ich auch direkt die gewürze dazugeben
also salz pfeffer paprika und bergbahnen
traut das habe ich jetzt aus dem garten
ihr könnt eure gano thymian majoran
nehmen und auch gerne schafe
paprikapulver aber ich koche nicht mehr
so scharf seitdem die kinder eben alles
mit essen und dann versuche ich mich
sowieso zurückzunehmen und scherf lieber
selber nach
und den gebe ich denke also hier einfach
nur noch ein bisschen köcheln bis die
champignons auf weich sind
perfekt also ich finde die füllung jetzt
wunderbar abgeschmeckt habe ich sie
schon mit salz und pfeffer und jetzt
oliver ich hätte mir gern eins mit chris
und ich habe mir jetzt gesagt dass sich
hier noch etwas frischkäse dazu gibt
damit die cremige füllung wird also noch
200 gramm frischkäse rein und
schnittlauch auf das meiste so
verstörend oder wenn wir kein catering
service wir uns einfach brote geschmiert
mettmann ist trocken brot mit butter und
kresse und salz
dann schauen wir uns einfach immer
wieder neu erfinden und zeigen wie
verrückt diese welche ist neulich
schrieb eine so ich glaube sie ist
schwanger
denn immer wenn sie schwanger ist immer
noch immer ich war zwei mal schwach wenn
eben alle 100 mal
denn immer wenn sie schwanger ist wird
sie verrückt und lustig das stimmt gar
nicht dass ich nur raus aus mehr
ich bin immer verrückt und lustig ja
[Gelächter]
also bitte lass ich bin nicht schwanger
mein gott
außerdem kann es voll verletzt und sein
stellt euch mal vor ich würde versuchen
schwanger zu werden und es klappt und
wenn man dann eine frau immer wieder
fragt bist du schon
also ich frage mich ob man schwanger ist
denn ich kenne einfach zu viele
geschichten zu viele missglückt der
schwangerschafts versuche ich finde
schon dass er traurig aber nein ich bin
nicht schwanger und nein ich habe es
noch nicht vor
die füllung letztlich erzählt stehen da
hefeteig ist gleich soweit und ich
geniesse landkreise brot
das ist durch gute und ich nehme jetzt
hier im mai blech das hat 32 zentimeter
im durchmesser also ist das mittelgroße
ich habe ich noch etwas butter und kann
es hier bei niedriger stufe schmelzen
also wirklich niedrig 1 oder 2 ist
wirklich maximum und ich mache jetzt
hier 20 buchteln raus
ein kleines bisschen mehr brauche ich
hier und macht es hier erst mal 20
portionen
so können dass euch zum verein teilen
wie werde ich mit ihm ab ich werde man
sich nicht schützen
1440 gramm geteilt 20 70
sie sind ungefähr
stimmt das
und spart sogar schon fast richtig als
ungefähr 72 kam
[Musik]
jetzt freue mich die noch zu schönen
kügelchen schwabl mir durch gelmer mit
kügelchen hügel
[Musik]
und dann nehmt ihr euch einen teig
kügelchen öffnet es leicht nicht zu sehr
weil dann ist das verschließen umso
schwieriger so ungefähr handflächen groß
und ich nehme jetzt den mittleren eis
portionierer ich hoffe dass uns selbst
von den fraktionen her gut aufgeht so
leicht gehäuft jetzt gibt es die füllung
in die mitte und verschließt die buchten
ganz vorsichtig einfach mit den fingern
zupfen und deswegen habe ich jetzt auch
vorher diese kugeln geformt damit die
bucht ist auch eine schöne glatte
oberfläche haben ansonsten mache ich
meist so dass ich es einfach aus der
form direkt vorm mit der zeit hat man
auch echt die übung geht es auch immer
besser und ich kenne auch eine version
dann nimmt man das hackfleisch vermischt
alles so miteinander form kleine
bällchen und gibt sie dann rein aber
dann ist es halt so dass wenn man am
ende rein bei es hat man so eine
frikadelle drin und die ist mir dann so
fest also so finde ich schon schön und
krimi und deswegen finde ich das kochen
vorher auch ganz okay es dauert zwar
kurz aber mal überbrückt ja sowieso die
wartezeit und daher finde ich das okay
ich mag es lieber cremig die für ein
bisschen reporter wie türkisch wie diese
kleinen teigtaschen
[Musik]
und ist er meist so dass hier die
oberfläche leicht am trocknet und dann
eben nicht mehr so klebt das heißt in
dem die unter unterseite legt die auf
die flache hand drückt es dann schön
auseinander man jetzt klebt praktisch
die innenfläche an meiner hand und jetzt
trägt aber um damit die klebrige seite
erinnern ist dann lassen sie sich
nämlich super verschließen und die
oberfläche ist aber dann schön
angetrocknet clips immer schön gleich
zusammen
[Musik]
habe ich hier das blech mit der butter
und vista warst du nimmst bisschen was
von der butter streicht sie auch an den
rand das ist kein guter gucken das
findbuch können und lege ich die erste
in die mitte und dann einfach in drei
reihen drumherum
gucken wir mal wie es läuft also
normalerweise werden buchteln dann noch
mit butter bestrichen
ach das ist doch schön
vielleicht doch noch mit butter drauf
bisher muss noch obendrauf es tut mir
leid aber ich hab noch mutter war also
ein bisschen schmolzen der butter
obendrauf
was ist halt doch bisher was ist heute
los hier
aha kaum gibt es erst dann kommt der
mars-rover das sieht aus wie ein schönes
bild ich habe euch buchteln gehalt guck
mal wie schön die aussehen
hast du noch bestreuen ich gucke in
meiner schublade
wisst ihr was ich erfülle euch jeden
wunsch ich nehme sesam und monat
ich glaube die fuchtel jetzt in den
kalten backofen
ihr könnt sie auch gerne vorher einfach
aufgehen lassen abgedeckt eine halbe
stunde damit es einfach schön luftig
werden und dann im heißen backofen
backen oder eben wie gesagt die
aufheizzeit einfach nutzen
ich stelle jetzt hier 170 grad ober
unterhitze und während der ofen dann auf
heißt können die buchteln aufgehen und
backen dann eben auch gleichzeitig wenn
ihr in den dampf backofen habt könnt ihr
auch noch dampf stufe 1 1 stellen oder
einfach so backen und ich denke so 35
bis 40 minuten dann sind sie fertig und
wenn ihr jetzt in einem heißen backofen
macht zins 25 bis 30 ungefähr 10 minuten
ich hab gerade überlegt 35 bis 40 in
zehn minuten weniger 25 bis 30 jahren
war ich total verwirrt ich rechne
einfach mit einer live wobei matte echte
stärke war
[Musik]
ich brauchte sind gebacken
selbst jetzt hier noch ein bisschen zum
abhören zur seite gestellt und jetzt
gibt's noch eine juli dazu
juli das ist im prinzip so was wie eine
mayonnaise aber mit viel knoblauch roli
knoblauch und olivenöl müsste es heißen
im prinzip wie gesagt eine mayonnaise
sie besteht aus öl und knoblauch zu
gleichen teilen als die schmeckt
wirklich super lecker die zubereitung
ist auch ganz einfach ihr müsst nur
beachten dass das ei frisch ist weil es
eben so verzerrt wird für die oli
verwende ich 3 knoblauchzehen 1 einen
esslöffel essig einen halben teelöffel
zucker einen teelöffel senf salz und
pfeffer und 250 km rapsöl
ihr könnt rapsöl nehmen oder olivenöl
oliven und schmeckt natürlich etwas
stärker im geschmack oder sonnenblumenöl
also da entscheidet ihr einfach selbst
ich gebe jetzt zuerst ist ein in eine
rührschüssel bei mir haben jetzt alle
zutaten zimmertemperatur dann kommt er
es sich dazu habe sie ein apfel etwas
dann zucker
[Musik]
salz und pfeffer
[Applaus]
jetzt werden die zutaten so lange gemixt
bis die masse einfach schön weiß cremig
ist
ich nehme jetzt dafür übrigens wenn ihr
das sehen könnt nicht die mixa die könnt
ihr auch nehmen aber ich habe hier
einfach noch ein zusätzliches teil
obendrauf für milchschaum und ich glaube
für mayonnaise ist es auch ganz gut
schneebesen geht auch kopfsache es wird
schnell gerührt hätte im prinzip auch
wichtig dass sie ein hohes gefäß habt
damit ihr einfach diese wenige masse
eben auch schon auf schreiben könnt das
geht in einem flachen gefäß nicht so gut
und deswegen kippe ich das hier auch
damit ich einfach die ganze masse direkt
unter diesem element ab und dann eben
alles schön schaumig schlagen kann jetzt
langsam geht es langsam das öl zu gießen
damit ist nun auch nehmen
und fotogen wird und sich nicht ab
worden
und dadurch für die konditionen für
pfeffer und nehmen
[Musik]
perfekt
richtig schöne creme falls ihr euch doch
mal nicht gelingt und sie wirklich
gewinnt und nicht so wirklich
zusammenhält könnt ihr auch noch mal ein
eigelb dazu geben das eigelb lüftern
dass die masse sich schön verbindet aber
wie gesagt wenn ihr alles schön langsam
macht die zutaten alle zimmer warm sind
ihr fleißig rührt und die eier masse
schlagt dann kann eigentlich nichts
schief gehen
am anfang sieht so aus also wird es
nicht klappen aber es klappt vertraut
mir und damit dass jetzt eine juli wird
und keine langweilige mayonnaise kommen
jetzt auch die knoblauchzehen mit rein
beim stabmixer mit mix aus songs einfach
den mixa die messer benutzen oder
einfach fein dazu reiben oder mit der
knoblauchpresse dazu geben
[Musik]
die creme ist nichts für leute die noch
im zahnarzttermin haben am gleichen tag
oder am nächsten oder übernächsten so
apfel und probieren
[Musik]
sorry wir müssen jetzt halt vor dem
probieren singen
ich werde gezwungen sie zwingt mich
[Musik]
ich finde wir sollten jedes rezept mit
nämlich ihr gesang untermauern und
probieren probieren steppich aufgerissen
das ist meine hier ihre eigene ja hier
nimmt hier die kammer sowie kreisen okay
aber dann kann es eigentlich in die irre
knoblauch es tut mir leid aber richtig
gut
und oh mein gott die sind so luftig so
ich hasse das wort fluffig aber es
stimmt diese sind mega fluffig das ist
richtig und ich hatte noch nie herzhafte
buchteln ich glaube es ist favorisiert
ist juni zu leben so leben ein bisschen
und macht das rezept so also macht es
nach mit 3 knoblauchzehen ich hatte es
auch vor allem die wahl auf der schürze
da kann ich eine woche nicht mehr aus
dem haus gehen außer alle menschen essen
knoblauch die aioli die aloe war ja auf
drei schälchen aufgeteilt in einer
schale haben jetzt eine knoblauchzehe
ich ordentlich nicht verständlich aber
körperlich gesund ja sehr gesund die
zahlen sind ein thema genau und gut fürs
herz hätte kreislauf in schwung war also
werke nichts mit unserer idee weiter
juli mit bisschen butter definitiv nach
wir machen sie auch noch mal öfter jetzt
[Gelächter]
deshalb trete ich übrigens immer um auf
der lippe einlösen
[Musik]
ciao ciao